Okay, good morning. Uh, today we are
doing the Russian Empire and to review,
we've done America and Britain so far
and we've discussed the civilization.
Today we'll do Russia and then on
Thursday we'll start Germany. Um, let's
simplify the differences between these
three great modern civilizations that
are struggling for world domination even
today. So as we discussed last week um
the defining characteristics of the
Anglo-American civilization is their
belief in utilitarianism. Okay. They
want they want to know what is
practical, what
works. Um their idea of Christianity is
the supreme god is a force that elects.
And what this means is that um not
everyone will go to heaven. only a
minority will go to heaven and this
minority are those who have proven
themselves the most worthy. Okay. The
last idea of the Anglo-American
civilization is that the meaning of life
is the pursuit of life, liberty and
happiness. Essentially the pursuit of
wealth. Okay. So that these are the um
characteristics of the Anglo-American
civilization. Um on Thursday we will
start the German German civilization and
what you will um see is that the Germans
are very different. Um they are not
utilitarians they are very idealistic
very
romantic. Um for them God is a force
that demands you to be your very
best. Okay not a few people but
everyone. And the Germans believe in the
unity of will. Okay. everyone has to
work together and promote German
civilization. Today we do the Russians,
okay? And the Russians are a very
different civilization. Uh first of all,
they're much more fatalistic than the
Germans and the Americans. They don't
believe that you have control over your
life. They believe that you can only
accept what is given to you and make the
most out of it. Um for them, God is a
force that redeems and saves all. God is
merciful. God is forgiving. Okay, this
is a very different conception from both
the German and the Anglo-American
conception. The last concept that we
will look at today is for them the um
essence of life is to understand the
mystery, miracle and authority of the
human heart. Okay. So whereas the
Americans and British place an emphasis
on science on mastering the world um uh
the material world and whereas the
Germans are extremely idealistic they
want an understanding of existence. The
Russians are focused very much on the
human heart. Okay. For the Russians the
greatest mystery um the most knowledge
is within the human heart. And this is
what we will focus on uh today.
Okay. So, um the leading question for
today's class, the question that I'm
sure you're all interested in is why did
Putin invade Ukraine? What is driving
the Russian invasion of Ukraine? And um
there are lots of easy explanations.
What I will show you today is the answer
is actually extremely complicated. What
Putin himself has said in multiple
interviews is there are historical
um sociological philosophical issues at
work here and westerners don't really
understand what he's saying. Okay. So
what I'm going to do today is I'm going
to explain to you what he really
means. Okay. So um if you look at the
year 1300
um you could not expect Moscow to
eventually become the Russian Empire. At
this point in history the Mongols have
controlled most of the world and Moscow
along with other areas um in the um
empire there are vassal states. Okay
they pay taxes they pay tribute they
provide troops to the Mongol Empire. But
it's the Empire that is the um
great power at this
stage. So but so why but if you look at
history okay you will see a very similar
pattern where it's not really the
greatest power that will eventually uh
overwhelm everyone. It's always the
marginal power. Okay. So going back to
and reviewing what we've learned so far,
remember when we discussed the Aztecs,
the Aztecs were very much a poor
isolated
um backward people. Um but eventually
through innovation, through tenacity,
for resilience, they will come to
conquer most of Central America. Same
thing with theQing dynasty in China.
Right at this stage in history, maybe
300, 400 B.CE, C, you would not expect
theQing Empire, uh, theQing dynasty to
overwhelm all of China and become
China's first great national empire.
Maybe the Chu, maybe the way Chi,
they're all stronger at this point in
history, but it's the marginal uh power
that seems weak at first that will
overwhelm. Same thing with Macedon.
Okay. At this point in history in the
year uh 400 300 BCE it's Athens, Sparta
uh thieves that are powers but
eventually Macon will not only over will
not only overwhelm the great peninsula
but they will go over to Persia and
conquer the Persian Empire as well. Same
thing with Rome. Rome um at this point
in history maybe 500 B.CE it is the
weakest of all these Italian states. Um
the uh itricians are the main power and
they are the poorest, the weakest, the
smallest of all these great tribes but
eventually over uh the next centuries
they will conquer everyone. Same thing
with the Franks. Um after the Roman
Empire, the Franks will slowly expand
from central Europe and overwhelm uh
most of Europe to create the Holy Roman
Empire. Okay? And the same thing with
the Prussians. Uh next class we'll
discuss the Prussian Empire which
becomes modern day Germany. They start
off as this landlocked
um um isolated central area within
uh Europe but eventually they will
spread out to conquer all of
uh Germany. Okay. So the lessons we can
learn from uh these case studies is
there are three forces that drive these
marginalized powers to become the great
power of the day. Okay. So for Moscow
it's a pro constant process of creative
destruction. First of all open
cooperative competition. So they're
always surrounded by these adversaries
and because they don't really lack and
because they don't have natural
defenses, they don't have mountains,
rivers, um it forces them to be tough
and unified in order to feed their
enemies. And it's toughness and unity
that will allow Moscow to emerge as a
great power um in Central Asia.
Advantage by disadvantages. Okay, you're
better off being weak because if you're
weak, it forces you to be innovative and
open. Okay, so they say um necessity is
the mother of invention. The last factor
is vaselage. Okay, so the idea that
historical humiliation and subjection
force reflection and resilience because
Moscow for the longest time was
subjected um to vassels by the Mongols.
It forced them to be humble and humility
allows you to reflect deeply on your own
weaknesses to be honest with yourself
and eventually triumph over all your
adversaries. Okay, so these are the
three factors that will drive the
massive expansion of Moscow. Okay,
Moscow starts off as this very small
principality within the Mongol Empire
and then it will eventually become the
successor to the Mongol
Empire. All right. Um so let's look at
the origins of the uh of Russia. So the
history is we have to go back to the
Viking age, right? This this is about
the year
900,000, right? So the Vikings are in uh
Sweden and Denmark and Norway. And
because it's so poor and because it's
becoming overly populated um they will
start to expand over to England to
Greenland to other areas and then sorry
can you open the door and then they will
also move east. Okay. Why are they
moving east? because all the great
wealth of of the age is located in the
Bison Empire in Egypt and as well as the
Abbisid Empire um in Iraq and Persia.
Okay. So they're they they're here to
establish trading post and when they
establish trading poles what will happen
is that first of all they will intermar
with the local Slavic population as well
as the um steps people. Okay. They will
also build an alliance with the
Bisantine Empire and become basically
vassels to the Bisantines. All
right.
Um what will happen is over time their
trading posts will become cities and
they will expand outwards. So the
tradition the custom at at this stage in
history is if you're noble
um you must go and conquer new lands.
When you conquer new lands, you can
enslave the people to work for you.
Okay, this is a very feudal system.
Okay, so this forces a process of
constant expansion. If they don't
expand, they only fight amongst
themselves. So the Kian ruse expands
very quickly throughout this uh area. Um
eventually they'll all be conquered by
the Mongols and when the Mongols leave
it leaves a vacuum of great powers.
Okay. So the great power of this age is
the grand ducky of Lutherania. Okay. Um
Novagrad is also great power. Moscow is
the weakest. But again as I said over
time because it is weak it's forced to
be united. It's forced to be resilient.
It's forced to be innovative. And over
time what it will do is it will
overwhelm uh Novagrad and become the
Russian Empire. Okay. And as you can
see, what will happen is the Russian
Empire will expand really quickly until
it absorbs the entire uh Mongol Empire
as well as unify all of um northern
Asia. Okay, it is now the largest
landmass in the
world. Okay. Um so um the thing to
understand about the Russians is that
even though it's a very uh large
country, most of it is not able to be
cultivated. Okay? So it has very uh low
population. Most of the wealth is
located in the in over here. Okay? This
is basically Ukraine. This is what's
driving the invasion because
historically most of the wealth uh in
Russia has been located in the Ukraine
area. And if you go over here, it's
basically just forest and mountains. So
why are they moving
uh eastwards when there's very little
resources here? The answer is fur. Okay,
fur. Uh fur is very valuable commodity.
They go and they um they trade fur for a
living. Okay. Um some of the great sars
of Russian history is Ivan the great and
his son is Ivan the Terrible who will
expand Russia uh greatly. Okay. Um the
thing to understand about Russian
expansion is it's really not driven by
state policy. It's really driven by
oppression and misery. And what this
means is that because Russia is
essentially a feudal state, the only way
to build a better life is if you escape
eastwards and you basically eth
ethnically cleans that area and build a
new settlement. Okay? So that's what's
driving this. And what will happen is as
these people move further eastwards, the
state will follow them in order to
collect taxes. Okay? And sometimes the
state will inter intervene in order to
protect these people from u their
adversaries in the local areas. But it's
a very brutal process that takes
centuries. And the Russians win out
because uh there's more of them and also
because they have musketss and the local
people do not have
musketss. Okay. So as you can see the
expansion is very rapid only applies
about 300 years.
Um and as I mentioned it is an extremely
brutal process. Okay. So these are
paintings of
uh the brutality involved in this
eastward expansion. It involves ethnic
cleansing. It involves enslaving people.
Okay. Yeah. It's a brutal process and
these paintings are meant to capture the
brutality of the
process and you can see the misery
involved. Okay, so these people who are
being conquered, they're either being
ethnically cleansed or they're being
forced to immigrate or they're being
enslaved. Um it's a very similar process
with the Americans.
Um and these will eventually come become
the two great empires
um of the 20th century as well as really
the 21st century. Okay. So the Americans
have the same situation where they're
expanding westwards and the Russians are
expanding eastwards. The difference is
this. The Americans are expanding
westwards for better opportunities.
Okay. To build up to to get wealthy to
build a better life. The Russians are
expanding eastwards because they are
trying to escape misery and oppression
and slavery. Okay? That's a difference.
And because of this difference, even
though there there have many
similarities, the
fundamental belief systems of these two
nations are very different. Americans
are fundamentally
optimistic. Russians are fundamentally
fatalistic, pessimistic.
Okay. All right. Um, so let's summarize
the differences between the Slavic East,
the Russian East, and the Germanic West.
Okay. Uh, Slavic gives us the word
slave. Why? Because for the longest
time, the Slavs in Europe, in Eastern
Europe, they were pagans. They weren't
Muslims. They weren't Christians. And
the custom at that time is you can only
enslave people who are not of your
religious belief. Okay? So, the pagans
were the most valuable people because
they can be they can be be enslaved by
everyone. So Vikings came uh the Muslims
came the Christians came to enslave the
Slavic people and sell them off to the
Bisantines the bassetss
um and that's why we get the word slave.
Okay so let's look at the three major
differences between Russia and Germany.
The first major difference is that the
Russians believe they are here to the
Bison Empire which is a very top-down
centralized bureaucracy and this is
something we discussed uh before the
Germans uh believe they are here to the
Holy Roman Empire which is a
confederation. Okay, as we discussed
when we discussed the Holy Roman Empire,
it was impossible for anyone to conquer
all of Europe. And so um the Holy Roman
Empire was based on consensus. It was
based on diplomacy. Okay. It was based
on intermarriage. So this is a much more
democratic much more uh independent
system than the bisonantines. Second
major difference is the Germans have the
Catholic Church. The Russians have
something called the Eastern Orthodox
Church. This sounds similar but what I
will show you as we move on is it's
actually night and day. Okay. These two
belief systems are extremely different.
Third major difference is um Germanic
west the Germans they are culturally
coherent. They believe they speak the
same language. They believe that they
come from the same culture. Whereas the
Russian Empire it is culturally
incoherent. Okay. It uh encompasses a
vast array of different cultures,
languages
uh and belief systems. All
right. Okay. So the Russian Empire
starts with Peter the Great. And what
Peter the Great does is he modernizes
Russia and forces a decisive war with
Sweden, which is at Europe right now,
the great military power. Okay? So for
most of Russian history, the European
powers didn't really take Russia
seriously. And they just thought that
the Russians are part of Asia. They're
really not part of Europe. And it was
Peter the Great who's determined to
westernize Europeanize Russia and prove
Russia a European power. Okay. And he
does that
um for three reasons. All right. Let's
Oh, sorry. Sorry. For many reasons.
Okay. He does it because Russia right
now is an empire and as an empire you
need a unifying ideology, a philosophy.
And for the Russians for the longest
time even Putin shares this philosophy
is they believe they are trying to
restore the biscan empire and be the
third Rome and save civilization. Okay.
So so what do I mean by this? All right.
So the first Rome of course was Rome.
Second Rome was Carenapole. The third
Rome now is Moscow. And not only that
but they believe they are the true
heroes to the Christian tradition. All
these other Christian religions out
there Catholic, Protestant, they are
corrupt forms. It's the Orthodox Church
that is the true here to the Roman uh
Christianity. All right. Um quest for
military supremacy means that right now
at this stage in history all the great
um militaries are in Europe. Okay.
So eur Russia basically needs to copy
imitate uh the Europeans. So what so
what Russia does is it imports a lot
actually German soldiers and mercenaries
to learn German military technique quest
for absolute power means that all these
SARS Peter the great captain the great
they're in they're interested in
centralizing authority they want to
remove this feudal system and
centralized power and all in their hands
okay delusion of authority of church and
nobility so uh in Europe the Catholic
church is above the kings okay so Peter
the great wants to subject the church to
his authority as well as the nobility.
Uh right now the great threat the great
rival to the Russians is the Ottoman
Empire. Okay. And and last is the
contempt of Asia. Okay. So um even
though the Mongols probably influence
the Russians much more than the Vikings,
the Russians believe the Vikings are
their true um um ancestors, not the
Mongols. They try to they try to like
erase the Mongols from their own
history. They're kind of ashamed of
it. Okay. So again um as I mentioned at
this time in Europe about the year 1700
Sweden is the great military power of
the age and Peter the Great and Charles
the 12 of Sweden they get into this
major conflict and Peter the Great um is
not that great. Okay. Um he he has a lot
of issues, but Charles II is a complete
disaster. And the reason why is he's a
young man. He's only about 27 when he
invades Russia who fancied himself as
Anton the Great. Okay. And as we
discussed, Anton the Great was very
problematic because he was very
tyrannical and also because he believed
he was invincible. So Charles the Great
decides to go invade
Russia. And this is a disaster. Why?
Because Peter great will um use
something called a scorch earth policy.
Basically he knows that he cannot on the
battlefield defeat the Swedes. So what
the Russians do is they retreat and burn
down all the fields. So the army cannot
feed itself. Okay, this is called scorch
earth. And this is important because
uh this is how the Russians will defeat
Napoleon in 1812. And this is important
because this is how the Russians will
defeat uh the Germans in uh World War
II. Okay. So uh this is very sim this is
a very uh familiar pattern in
history.
Um as I mentioned the great enemy of
Russia at this time are the Ottomans.
Okay. And so the Russians and the
Ottomans will clash over the
um Cruma. Okay. The Crimea. And this
will lead to something called the Korean
War uh in
1854. Okay. So, Peter the Great again,
he wins because uh Charles II um makes
disastrous military decisions during
this war. But this is this begins the
Russian Empire. Okay. For the first
time, Russia is now considered a great
European power because it's defeated the
great military power of Europe, Sweden.
Okay. So these are paintings celebrating
the great Russian victory over the
Swedes. So after this victory, Russia
will expand very
greatly. And then um after the Peter the
Great, the the the next great
westernizer of the Russian Empire is
Katherine the Great. Uh what's important
first to remember about um Katherine the
Great is she's actually not Russian.
She's actually German. She's she was
born in Prussia and she married into the
Russian noble family. It was very common
at this stage for the European powers to
intermar with each other and most of the
uh Russian nobility a lot of them
actually have German blood and they
actually spoke French at home. Okay. So
so uh this Russianization created a
process where the nobility now is very
European. They speak French. they have
German ancestry and the um the peasants
are Slavic. Okay. And so this creates a
massive divide in Russia. Captain the
great will extend uh Russia greatly as
you can see from this map. The great um
event that basically
frustr is the defeat of Napoleon in
1812. Napoleon, as we know, the great
conqueror. He invades Russia in 1812 and
he defeats the Russian army. But what
the Russians do that no one can possibly
imagine they would do is they burn down
the capital, Moscow. Okay, Moscow is the
cultural capital. It is the heart and
soul of the Russian Empire. And they
burn it down to starve Napoleon's army.
And the Europeans thought this was a
incredible act of barbarism. Okay. But
for the Russians, they believed it was
an incredible act of self-sacrifice that
saved the Russian Empire. In fact, uh
the great Russian composer, he wrote a
symphony dedicated to uh uh celebrating
the victory over Napoleon called 1812
overture. Have you guys heard the
overture? All right, let let me play it
for Okay.
I'm pretty sure
[Music]
[Applause]
you so the
Russians thought that by getting
Napoleon by making a sacrifice they not
only saved Russia but they saved all of
Europe. They saved Western civilization
basically.
[Music]
Okay. Okay. So, I'm sure you you guys
have heard of it, right? Okay. But this
is to celebrate uh the freedom of
Napoleon by Tchaikovski.
Okay. Um, after the defeat of Napoleon
though, the Europeans take notice of
Russia, especially Britain. Remember,
Britain is this great naval power that
is dedicated to a divide and conquer
policy of of Europe. They basically gang
up against whoever is the growing power
in Europe. So as as Russia's as Russia
is growing uh the British encourage the
Ottomans and the French to unite against
Russia to prevent Russia expansion into
the Ottoman Empire. Eventually uh the
Russians will defeat the Ottoman Empire
but the Korean war is a major setback
for the Russians and this creates
something called the great game where
the Russians um are now being helmed in
by the by the British. Okay. So the
British and the Russians now will now
will now fight for supremacy over
Central Asia. A disaster the next
disaster for the for the Russians is the
Russell Japanese war where Russia gets
heavily defeated by the Japanese and
this sort of instigates revolutionary
settlement and fever in Russia. And of
course, what follows next is the great
disaster, the first war, where the
Russians are defeated mightily by the
Germans. And this creates something
called the 1917 Revolution,
which destroys the Russian Empire and
creates the uh Soviet Empire. Okay. Um
so this is just a brief history. We'll
go into the revolution at a future date.
Okay. Okay, it's a very important event
and I I want to dedicate a whole class
to it. But that's a brief background
um of the Russian Empire. Okay, so now
let's talk about the civilization. And
as um I discussed westernization has a
ma has been a major trend in Europe. But
because of westernization, there are
three major
contradictions that are created within
the uh Russian Empire. Okay. And these
three contradictions will go on to
create Russian civilization. Okay, these
contradictions are it's both European
and Central Asian. Okay, it's both
Viking and It's both it's both um
Slavic as well as Tartar. Okay, so
there's a lot of e ethnicities, a lot of
cultures within Russia. And there's a
contradiction. Second contradiction is
it fancy itself as a Christian Orthodox
nation. In fact, the true Christian
nation, but it's also very pagan. Uh
remember there's this massive um east
eastward expansion
um in the process um there's a lot of
war there's a lot of violence okay it's
very pagan and the peasantry um even to
this day maintain a lot of pagan rituals
a lot of pagan beliefs and the third
great contradiction is between
enlightenment and empire so Katherine
the great who was Prussian she tried to
saw herself as an enlightened monarch.
She was best friends with Voltater. They
they never met but they were pen pals
and she saw herself as an enlightened
despot who was trying to bring reason
and justice and goodness to Russia.
Okay. But at the same time it's an
empire and it's a brutal empire that um
uh and the Russians engage in a lot of
barbarism. Okay. So this is also a
massive
contradiction. And so if you study
Russian civilization, okay, it is unique
because of these three major
contradictions. So let me show you how
they influence Russian arts and
literature. Okay. Um let's look at some
of the major Russian cultural
figures. And um there are too many to
name, okay? There's just a lot of them,
but I'll just go through the most
famous. Um this is actually Pushkin who
is considered the Shakespeare of Russia.
He's the great innovator of Russian
language. He basically modernizes the
language and he's a poet um and a very
romantic figure in Russia. He's
basically the national poet of Russia.
Something really interesting about him
is his grandfather was an African
general. Okay. Who who who was uh who
who became a noble in Russia. So he's
about 1/8 black and he's very proud of
it. And so what's important for us to
remember is again for most of of human
history race was not a concept. Okay?
People didn't really care what race you
were. Um this is Anton Chvk who is
considered the greatest short story
writer in human history. Okay. uh music
Russian music is extremely uh Russian
music is just it's beautiful. Okay,
where I'll I'll play you some uh some
clips of Russian music. Okay, this is
Glanka was a very famous composer. The
most famous composer of course is
PeterChaikovski. Okay, and he is famous
for three ballets that are still
performed today.
um the Nutcracker which is performed
Christmas. This is his most famous Swan
Lake. Okay. So, let's let's hear some
music from Swan Lake just so you can you
can appreciate the beauty u and the
depth of Russian music.
What what's astonishing about this music
is that this music can flow into your
essence, your soul. Okay? This music
comes from the soul. And to create music
this beautiful, your soul must suffer.
Okay? Your soul must engage in misery,
pain and suffering in order to create
such beauty.
[Music]
Okay. So this is just um uh haunting
beautiful music that Tchaikovsky
created. Okay. Uh Sleeping Beauty is
also a really famous play by um um
Tchaikovski. Igor Shvinsky is considered
the first great modern composer and he
composed something called the rights of
spring. Okay, this is 1913. It was first
performed in Paris. It was so
revolutionary that it caused a riot uh
within the music hall. Um this
uh ballet what it tries to do is it
tries
to fuse the pagan tradition into
modernity. Okay. Uh I'm going to play
some excerpts from the rights of spring.
And you can see how revolutionary this
music is. And and and I want and what I
want you to notice is this music
expresses encapsulates the
contradictions within Russian
civilization between the pagan and the
Christian.
[Music]
You can feel the rawness, the energy,
the violence, the
aggression, the sensuality.
[Music]
Okay. So this musical, this ballet, it's
about the rights of spring. So it goes
back to a Slavic tradition where they
celebrate the mother goddess and it's
spring. So they to celebrate the
transition uh perform games and have
festivals and what
ends what ends the spec festivities is
the sacrifice of a maiden. Okay. She
will dance until she dies and when she
dances to her death her her heart will
explode. Okay. And this symbolizes how
the mother god is gives life to the
world by making um by
dancing
and basically
um pouring out her blood into the world
in order for plants for uh the seasons
to change and then her heart will will
explode. And in this world, what's
important for us to understand
is it's all interconnected and it must
be balanced out and and harmonized. So
if the mother goddess sacrifices herself
in order for there be life, then the
maiden must sacrifice herself to thank
the mother goddess.
Okay. All right. So now let's move on to
Russian literature. In Russian
civilization, there are two great
prophets. They are Leo Toy Stoy and
Theodore Dossfki. Together they will
create uh modern Russian civilization,
the sensibilities, the beliefs, the
philosophies of modern um Russian
civilization. And what they're trying to
do is they're trying to reconcile the
contradictions within Russia through
their uh novels. Okay, these are the
great novelists uh in the human
tradition.
All right. So, Toy Story's most famous
novel is Anna Karinina, which is
considered also um the greatest work uh
of literature, the greatest novel ever
written. Okay. And I want to first read
some passages from Anacrina. This is the
beginning. Okay. This is most one of the
most famous beginnings in world
literature. Happy families are all
alike. Every unhappy family is unhappy
in its own way. Everything was confusion
in the Oblaskki's house. The wife had
discovered that the husband was carrying
on an an intrigued with a French girl.
Okay. So, what Toy Story is telling us
from the first couple paragraphs is
Russianization, Europeanization, it is a
process of corrupting the Russian
soul. Okay. The idea that you bring in a
French girl and the husband is gonna
sleep with her. It's
corruption. Okay, now this is this is
important because Yoblaskki the
husband they are now um engaged in a
divorce and Anacrin and Nina will come
from St. Petersburg to try to reconcile
husband and wife and Anakin and Nina
herself will commit adultery. she'll
fall in love with um a man named uh
Ronsky. They'll have a very passionate
affair and this passionate affair will
destroy uh both Ronssky and Anakarin
Nina and Aarina has a husband and a
child back at St. U Petersburg. She asks
for divorce. The husband won't give it
to her. U and then she slowly falls into
depression and then she commits to
killing herself. Okay, so let's look at
look at her the monologue.
that she has within herself before she
decides to kill herself. Okay, so she's
trying to explain why she's unhappy. My
love keeps growing more passionate and
egoistic. Okay, selfish. While his is
winning and waning, and that's why we're
drifting apart. So, they've been
together for a long time, but she feels
that Ronsky is no longer as passionate
as he used to be, while she is becoming
more passionate. And there's no help for
it. He has everything for me and I want
him more and more to give him him
himself up to me entirely. He wants more
and more to get away from me. We walk to
meet each other up to the time of our
love and then we have been irresistibly
driven in different directions and
there's no altering that. He tells me
I'm insanely jealous and I have told
myself that I am insanely jealous but
it's not true. I'm not jealous but I'm
jealous and I sorry I'm not jealous but
I'm unsatisfied. Okay, this is the most
important word unsatisfied.
Okay. It tells us that she's a very
selfish person who's using love as a way
to fill the void in her heart. She feels
that this relationship, this adultery
will give her meaning in her life. And
what she doesn't understand is when that
happens when you um try to possess
someone, you can't love that person
because love is really about um giving
yourself all to another person. Okay? So
think think about Dante. Dante never got
anything from Beatric but he loved her
regardless. Okay. So this is where
Anakarina fails. She doesn't really
understand what love is. Okay. And she's
very selfish. Also a huge problem for
Anakarina Nina
is because she betrayed her husband she
now fears that her h that Brony will now
betray her. Okay. So do you see the
psychology here? And that's why she
can't she can't love because she broke
the fundamental condition for love which
is
trust. Okay. So this is telling us that
the heart is a mystery. It's something
that you cannot reason out. Something
that you can never fully
understand. Okay. In
theory if you find someone more
attractive, if you think you're better
off with him, then you should go be with
him. Okay? That's western civilization
basically pursue your own happiness. But
what toys is telling us is the heart is
something you cannot master. Okay? Maybe
your mind you can master the reason the
logic you can master but the human heart
works by its own set of
logic and you must respect the human
heart. If you want to love then you must
give and not receive. If you want to
love base your love on trust. Do not
betray yourself. Do not betray others.
Okay, does that make sense? All right.
So, now let's move on to really the man
who who is at the heart and center of
Russian civilization. His name is
Theodore
Dosski. Okay, so let me give you some
background about Theodore Doss Dosski.
Um, both Toy
Stoski were extremely passionate
Christians. They really believed in they
believed in the Christianity. they and
they had deep empathy for the people
around them. Um, Toy Story was born very
wealthy, he he was of of the nobility,
he inherited a lot of money, but because
he was so distraught by the suffering
around him because his wealth was
basically based on the oppression of the
peasantry, right? He actually wanted to
give up all his money, he wanted to
throw it all away and become a beggar.
He wanted to become poor. And it was
only at the insistence of his family
that prevented him from doing what he
felt he felt his heart demanded of him.
Theo Dossi comes from the lower
nobility. His father was a doctor. Um
and as a young man he he was a
revolutionary and he particip
participated in these um literary
revolutionary circles. He wasn't violent
but he had these subversive ideas. So he
was he was arrested and he was condemned
to death. He was put in front of a
firing squad uh along with others who
were part of the subversion and at the
last minute he was his sentence was
commuted. He was spared by the SAR and
he was sent to hard labor in Siberia for
a number of years and this was a very
traumatic but it was also a extremely
enlightened experience for Dossi. It
made him think very deeply about the
meaning of life. Okay. So um he writes
something called Crime and Punishment
which is really the great novel of of of
Russian civilization. It has to do with
a man
Russov who he's young. He's brilliant.
He's a university student but he's poor.
And he decides that in order to escape
his circumstance, in order to control
his fate, he's going to murder a woman,
a potent broker who has a lot of money.
No one likes her. no one will miss her.
And then he will he will take her money
and then build a new life for himself.
Okay? And this will be become a basis
for his greatness. And he reasons out
that you know what as a great
individual, as a genius, I'm going to
contribute so much to humanity. So if I
kill a old woman no one likes, it won't
really matter. Okay? So he's been
thinking about this for like a long time
and he's all he's got it all reasoned
out. And what crime and punishment will
show us is reason is nothing. It doesn't
really matter. What matters is the
heart. Okay. All right. So,
um, first I want to talk about Dashk's
understanding of God. Okay. Which is the
Russian understanding of God. So, at a
bar at the beginning of the novel,
Rascanov meets an middle-aged man who's
a drunk. Okay? He's he's he's alcoholic
named Marmar Laddov. Okay, Mar Ladov.
And Mar Laddov um is extremely pitiful
man because what he's done is he's he's
uh he's like a middle-aged bureaucrat
um and he's been poor and he marries a
poor widow as well and they have like
four children to feed. So the widow
decides to prostitute
um M Marlo's daughter Sonia to make
money. Okay. And then Mar Millov in a
fit of tremendous regret, he goes and
finds a job. And this seems like it's
going to resolve all problems from the
family, right? But he does something
that no one really can predict or
expect. He decides to steal all the manu
all the money within the household, quit
his job, and get drunk every day. Okay?
And you hear this and you're like, um,
that makes no sense. But again, that's
the beauty of Russian literature. It's
it's focused on what what drives us
psychologically. It's not about what is
reasonable, what is logical. It's really
about what we what we do in these
circumstances. Okay? And
so Marlo, he's driven to despair because
he he feels he sacrificed his daughter.
Okay? He hates the fact that his
daughter has become a prostitute and he
cannot allow himself and his family to
live happily ever after now that his
daughter is a prostitute and that's why
he decides to be become alcoholic. And
then they talk about God. Okay, they
talk about God and what the nature of
God is. And this is very important for
us to understand Orthodox Christianity.
He says to Russo, why am I to be pity?
You say, "Yes, there's nothing to pity
me for. I ought to be crucified.
Crucified on a cross, not pity, not
pied. Crucify me, oh, judge me, crucify
me, but pity me. And then I will go of
myself to be crucified, for it is not
merrymaking, I seek, but tears and
tribulation. Do you suppose you that
sell that this pin of yours has been
sweet to me? It was tribulation I saw it
at the bottom of it. Tears and
tribulation and I found it and I have
tasted it. But he will pity us who has
had pity on all men. Who has understood
all men in all things. He is the one. He
too is the judge. He will come in that
day and he will ask where's the daughter
who gave herself for her cross
consumptive stepmother and for the
little children of another? Where's the
daughter who had pity upon the filthy
drunkard her earthly father undismayed?
by his beastness. And he will say, "Come
to me. I have already forgiven thee
once. I forgiven thee once. Thy sins
which are many are forgiven thee. For
thou has loved much. He will forgive my
sona. He will forgive. I know it. I felt
in my heart when I was with her just
now. He will judge and he will forgive
all the good and the evil, the wise and
the meek." Okay. So this God that the
Orthodox Christians celebrate, it's a
forgiving God. It's a merciful God. It
is a knowledgeable God, a wise God. Why?
Because we humans cannot be trusted to
be wise. We humans
are we suffer the mysteries of the
heart. We do not know ourselves. We do
not know our nature. And therefore we
are bound to suffer. And it's and God
understands this. And that's why God
will ultimately redeem us all when the
time is appropriate. Okay? So it's
fatalistic but at the same time it's
also optimistic. Okay. So um let us
summarize what the differences are
between the Protestant, Catholic and
Orthodox religions. Okay. And again
these are different branches of
Christianity and they seem similar but
in reality they are extremely different.
Okay. So the Protestants believe that we
choose to sin. We have free will. The
Catholics don't believe in free will.
They say we are born in sin. And the
Orthodox are fatalistic. They believe we
are born to sin. We cannot control our
own nature. Okay, that's the first major
difference. Second major difference is
only a few will be saved and redeemed.
Okay, the Protestant is a very
unforgiving religion. Only if you work
hard and become very wealthy will you be
saved. The Catholics believe that no,
everyone can be saved and redeemed. And
the Orthodox believe we are beyond
salvation and redemption. The human
heart is so dark, so mysterious that we
are beyond salvation and redemption. And
that that is why God is great because
only God can save and redeem us even
though we are beyond salvation and
redemption. Okay. Um the third major
difference is the protests believe that
our faith in God will save and redeem
us. The Catholics believe obedience to
God, oh sorry, obedience to the to the
church is what will save and redeem us.
where whereas the orthodox believe that
um only God can forgive us and if God
forgives us we can't really control
right so these are the three major
differences and this is important
because the orthodox religion is at the
heart and center of Russian
civilization okay so let's see how this
influences crime and punishment um so
this is a very important passage in
crime and punishment And we'll be
discussing this a lot as we move on.
Okay. So, here Rconovv, he's killed the
old lady. He's stolen her money, but now
he feels tremendous regret and he
doesn't know why. He can't sleep. Um
he's he he he he falls into sickness. He
doesn't know why this is happening
because he's already reasoned it out,
right? And then he meets Sonia who again
is Marlo Adolf's daughter and he and he
confesses to her what he's done and not
only that but he tries to explain why
he's done this. Okay, this is a very
important passage in western
civilization. I saw that if one waits
for everyone to get wise it will take
too long. So he's basically given up on
humanity. Afterwards, I understood that
that would never come to pass. That men
won't change and that nobody can alter
it and that it's not worth wasting
effort over it. Yes, that's so that's a
law of their nature, Sonia. That's so.
And I know now, Sonia, that whoever is
strong in mind and spirit will have
power over them. And who is greatly
daring is right in their eyes. He who
despises most things will be a lawgiver
among them. And he who dares most of all
will be most in the right. So it has
been till now and so it'll always be a
man must be blind not to see it. Okay.
So let's go back to the French
revolution. Ropes pier is someone who
fundament fundamentally believes that
everyone can be reasoned with that
reason exists in all of us. If we appeal
to reason then people will be
good. Napoleon is someone who believes
that I must lead the man. People are
weak. I must be strong. Okay. So what
what is saying is like I killed the old
lady because I'm trying to prove that
I'm Napoleon and not Ropes
PR. It's people like Napoleon who will
change history, who will save us. Ropes
Pierre can only be
sacrificed. Okay. And this is important
because what do wants to show in crime
and punishment is that this sort of
reasoning it sounds right but it goes
against the human heart and when that
happens when the reason and the heart
come into conflict the heart will always
triumph and this can only
lead into
misery. Also what will happen is that
very important uh thinkers like Fredick
Nichi as well as Stigman Ford they will
read this and interpret it in their own
way. Okay so Frederick Nishi will read
this and think no this makes sense. Okay
it's not that RC rcoff is wrong it's
that he didn't believe this enough. All
right so we'll talk about this next
class. All right. So, um, Rconovv, he's
being pursued by the police and it it's
obvious that he's the culprit. It's
obvious that he's guilty. But what
happens is someone else confesses to the
crime and we don't know why, but someone
else confesses to the crime. And at this
point, you would think
that is now happy. He's now free to do
whatever he wants. This shows that it is
God's will that he become great. is
God's will that he kill and become
great. But what happens next is he
decides to confess the crime. And the
confession is the confession strikes is
so striking and so nonsensical that the
law the legal system doesn't know really
doesn't know what to do with him. So
they basically sentence him to like hard
labor in Siberia for a few years. It's
it's the lightest crime. So it's the
lightest punishment he could have ever
received. Okay. And at this point you
would think that okay now he's happy
with himself because he killed someone
he felt regret and now he he's doing
some punishment and then eventually he
will be redeemed. Okay. But this causes
even more anxiety in him. It causes more
confusion in him. Okay. He did not
repent of his crime. He doesn't feel
guilty or remorseful for killing the
landl. Okay. At least he might have
found relief in raging at his stupidity,
as he had raged at the grotesque
blunders that had brought him to prison.
But not in prison, in freedom he fought
over and criticized all his actions
again, and by no means found them so
blundering and so grotesque as they had
seemed at the fatal time. In what way,
he asked himself, "Was my theory ster
than others that have swarmed and
clashed
them clash from the beginning of the
world? One has only to look at the
things quite independently, broadly and
in uninfluenced by commonplace ideas.
And my idea will be no means seem so
strange. Oh, skeptics and half punny
philosophers. Why do you halt halfway?
He he doesn't really understand what's
happening. He doesn't understand what
his problem is there. There was nothing
wrong with his plan. There's nothing
wrong with what he did. And now he's
being punished for what he did. and he
does he cannot escape his own reason.
All right. Now, um we have to go all the
way back to the beginning of this course
when we discuss Homer in the Iliad.
Remember, Achilles had the same problem.
Achilles saw the death of his friend
Petroas and he swore vengeance against
Hector and then he killed Hector and
then he started to mutilate Hector's
body. And after he did so, you would
think he would found relief and
ctharsis. But it only made him even more
depressed, more
miserable. Okay, so this is what Homer
and Dosski is telling us. Don't try to
reason things out. You try to re reason
things out, it will only make you
miserable because the truth is not
within reason. Okay? The truth is within
the human
heart. Why does my action strike them as
so horrible? He said to himself, "Is it
because it was a crime? What is meant by
crime? My conscience is at rest. Of
course, it was a legal crime. Of course,
the letter of the law was broken and
blood was shed. Well, punish me for the
letter of the law and that's enough. Of
course, in that case, many of the
benefactors of mankind who snatched
power for themselves instead of
inheriting ought to have been punished
at their first steps. But those men
succeeded. And so, they were right. And
I didn't. And so, I had no right to have
taken that step. is only in that he
recognized his criminality only in the
fact that he had been unsuccessful and
had confessed it. Okay, so he keeps on
reasoning and he decides that the source
of his misery is his weakness.
Okay, he killed the lady and he felt
regret for doing it. So this proves he's
not great. Napoleon would have felt any
regret. Julius Caesar would have laughed
about it. Alexander the Great would have
bragged about it. But he felt regret and
therefore he is weak. Okay. And that is
where his reasoning gets him and it
makes him more
miserable. Okay. But he finds salvation
in redemption and he finds salvation in
redemption in the love of Sonia. So
right now Rasharakov he's in Siberia in
prison and Sonia comes all the way to be
with him. Okay. And this this is how the
novel ends. How it happened, he did not
know. But all at once, something seemed
to seize him and fling him at her feet.
He wept and threw his arms around her
knees. For the first instant, she was
terribly frightened and she turned pale.
She jumped up and looked at him
trembling. At the same moment, she
understood and a light of infinite
happiness came into her eyes. She knew
and had no doubt that he loved her
beyond everything and that at last the
moment had come.
Okay. So this is what saves him. He love
he surreners himself to his love for
Sonia. He surrenders himself to Sonia
and that's what ultimately saves him. So
think back to the Iliad, right? What
saves Achilles? What saves Achilles is
Pry comes, kisses his hand, forgives
him, and then Achilles surreners himself
to Pry. They be they cry together. Okay.
So the source of salvation and
redemption is in our hearts not in
reason. You have to surrender yourself
to your love either for the other people
like Sonia or to God. That's where
salvation
is.
Okay. All right. So the other great
novel of Dosski is called the brothers
uh Kamazov. Okay. Um, and it's much too
long to read, but there's a very
important passage within a novel. It's
about a thousand pages called the Grand
Inquisitor. The Grand Inquisitor, he is
in charge of the Inquisition in Spain.
And as you know, the Inquisition in
Spain in 1492. It is horrific.
Christians um who have who are who have
their own ideas are being persecuted.
They're being slaughtered. Okay? And it
is a nightmare. So, what happens is
Jesus in heaven, he sees this pain. He
sees his suffering and it bothers him.
So he descends to the earth and when he
he's walking among men and right away
people recognize who he is. They um
worship him. Then he's dragged before
the Grand Inquisitor. He becomes a
prisoner to the Grand Inquisitor. And at
this point you would think the Grand
Inquisitor would be happy to see his
God. Instead he gets really really angry
at Jesus. Okay.
Thou did not love them at all. Thou who
did come to give thy life for them
instead of taking possession of man's
freedom, you did increase it and burden
the spiritual kingdom of mankind with
its suffering forever. You did desire
man's free love that he should follow
you freely, entice and taken captive by
you. In place of the rich and ancient
law, men must hereafter with free heart
decide for himself what is good and what
is evil, having only your image before
him as his guide. But did you not know
that he would at last reject even your
image and your truth if he is weighed
down with a fearful burden of free
choice? They will cry aloud at last that
the truth is not in you. For they could
not have been left in greater confusion
and suffering than you have caused,
laying upon them so many cares and
unanswered unanswerable problems.
Okay. Okay. So the idea here is this. So
one question that Jesus would have for
the Grand Inquisitor
is I sacrificed myself to free my people
to give people the free choice, free
will to love me freely. Instead, you
guys have built this great Christian
empire, the Catholic Church to oppress
everyone. Why did you do that? And the
grandchild is saying to him, it's
because people don't want free choice.
People don't want free will. They only
told what to do and you refuse to be
their king. You refuse to be their
emperor. You demand of them that they
reason that they love you freely. And
people don't want to don't want to do
that. So we had no choice but to oppress
people to build a church as a great
oppressive empire in order to liberate
people from the burden of free choice.
Okay, does that make sense? That's the
argument
here. You did come to give
Sorry. And how are the other weak ones
to blame because they could not endure
what the strong have endured? How's the
weak sort of to blame that it is unable
to receive such terrible gifts? Can you
have simply come to the elect and for
the elect? He's also saying to Jesus,
listen, you tell us that only by
believing in you freely can we be
redeemed. But that takes power. That
takes strength. What about those who
cannot do such a thing? How about the
weak? How about the lost? Will you
condemn them to
hell? That's not very
merciful.
Okay. Okay. So, this is how the story
ends. When the inquisitor sees speaking,
he waited some time for his prisoner
Jesus to answer him. His silence weighed
down upon him. He saw the prisoner have
listened intently all the time, looking
gently in his face and Emily not wishing
to reply. The old man long longed for
him to say something, however bitter and
terrible, but he suddenly approached the
old man in silence and softly kissed him
on his bloodless age lips. That was all
his answer. The old man shuddered, his
lips moved. He went to the door, opened
it, and said to him, "Go and come no
more. Come not at all. Never, never."
and he let him out into the dark alleys
of the town. The prisoner went away and
the old man the kiss glows in his heart
but the old man aderes to his idea. All
right. So what this is saying is
this the grand inquisitor he has
this novel. He has this philosophy of
why Jesus is bad of why we should
worship Satan of why we need an empire
why we need oppression. And it all makes
sense. Okay. And now Jesus must respond.
And Jesus responds with an act of
forgiveness, with an act of charity. He
kisses the Grand Inquisitor. And this is
exactly like Pry kissing Achilles,
right? Prime didn't go to reason with
Achilles. Pry went to kiss Achilles hand
to forgive him. Okay. Now, what's
important for us to understand is the
kiss glows in his heart. The old man
aderes to his idea. We can't change
someone's reason ever, but we can
change his heart with an act of mercy
and forgiveness and love. That's a
secret of humanity. The bay gets you
nowhere because people are stubborn
about their ideas. But the heart, even
though it's a
mystery, it's still loving. It's still
open. So if you touch it, you change
people forever.
Okay. All right. So, let's go back to
the original question. Why did Putin
invade Ukraine? What Putin has said over
and over again is we invaded Ukraine to
save Russian civilization. And that's
the answer because for the Russians,
their civilization is unique. It is
distinct and it's beautiful. It's worth
dying for. Okay. And the Okay. So um
even though the Russian Empire is gone,
Putin and Russians believe they are the
heirs to the empire. Okay. So let's look
at the differences between the American
civilization and the Russian
civilization to understand why this war
happened. The Okay, sorry. Um to be very
clear, this is how the America the
Russians see the Americans. Okay, does
that make sense? This is how the
Russians see the Americans. First of
all, they see the Americans extremely
materialistic. Okay. The only thing that
matters is things, buying things,
consuming things, obtaining things. But
not only that, but the Americans believe
that this is the only good in the world.
It's universal. Everyone, everyone wants
to buy things. So, we should just let
everyone buy things. And the Americans
are expansionist, which means that not
only is it right and good for people to
buy things, but
everyone should have the right to buy
things. So if you are preventing people
from buying things, you are a dictator.
You are a
tyrant. Okay? It is a responsibility to
liberate the world so we can all become
consumers. North Korea, Iran, they ought
to be liberated so that their people can
buy things from us. Okay? So that's the
American civilization. The Russians
think no, we are a spiritual people. We
are unique and we demand sovereignty. We
demand the right to live the lives we
choose to live. We demand the right to
be who we are.
Okay? And if it
means fighting America, if it means our
deaths, if it means sacrifice, we will
do so because our civilization is the
greatest in the world. Because our
conception of God is the correct
conception. Because our truth is the
real
truth. All right? So in other words,
this is really a class of
civilizations. And in a class of
civilizations,
um there can only be one winner. There
can be no compromise. Okay? So this war
in Ukraine, it is signaling something
much more devastating, much more um
cataclysmic. All right? And
so this is what's going on. All right?
That's it, guys. Any
questions? You
guys, is is this clear to
you? All right. Any
questions about what we discussed?
So
Yeah. Great. Yeah. So, right. So, you're
right. So, Russian literature is very
romantic and the idea of romantism, it's
a response to enlightenment, right?
Because in enlightenment with Khan and
Rouso, the argument is that reason is
the ultimate salvation. Through reason
you can save yourself and you can save
civilization. Okay? If it's logical,
then it's truthful. And the and the
romantics and the idealist, sorry, the
romantics are saying, "No, that's not
true." Okay? And what DSKV doskev is
saying is telling us that is that this
is nonsense. Reason doesn't really get
you anywhere. Okay? For reason, you can
reason that it's okay to to kill
millions of
people.
Okay? Logic doesn't really get you
anywhere. What what you have to do is
listen to your heart. Okay? Think about
the
heart. That's where the truth lies. All
right? So, so it's very much a reaction
against the enlightenment in Europe at
this time. Okay. Dossiia is also saying
like Toy Stoy westernization of Russia
is only corrupting us. What we need to
do is return to our true selves which is
an orthodox civilization. Okay. Because
that's that's a true
Christianity. All
right. Okay. So, great. Any more any
more questions?
is so pessimistic
and how can they still have
okay that's a great question okay so the
question and it's wonderful question if
I just said that Russians are fatalistic
then how are they so resilient okay so
um
um you can't logically figure it out
okay is is I can't logically explain to
you the feeling, but it's like knowing
that the world is doomed. Okay, we're
heading towards doom and what we do
isn't that important. It compels you to
live your best
life. Okay, so that's what meaning is.
meaning is with the knowledge that the
world is ultimately headed towards
doom, you as a person are compelled to
live your best life
nonetheless. Okay? And that's a very um
very pagan, very viking mentality. Okay?
So before Christianity, this was true
for for for for people. It's okay. the
world is going to end. What matters
is the life you lead
today. Okay. So, um um so I mean it's
problematic because I I mean
Americanization,
westernization has has such a huge
impact on global culture, right? And we
think that we think in very utilitarian
terms. We should do something because it
gets us somewhere. Okay? And Russian
civilization, it's it's very much like
we should do something because we know
it doesn't get us anywhere. And that's
what truth is. That's what life is
about. That's the meaning of life.
That's the purpose of life. Even though
you know it won't get you anywhere, you
should still do it because that's where
the meaning is. Okay. If you think about
it,
um um if you if you go deeper, then it's
also like a profound faith in God. Okay?
Like you know the world is ending but
you still work hard to make it better.
And that's what faith in God really
is. Does that make sense? If you know
like if you do something and God rewards
you, that's not faith really. Does that
make sense? Okay. So, so I I I I
understand it's really hard for us to
understand, but what I'm trying to show
you in this class is it's hard for us to
understand because we think in a certain
way. And if you think in a certain way,
you have to use logic and reason and
language. And what do the CCFC and Toy
Story is telling us is like that's very
limiting. Okay. Sometimes you have to
listen to your heart and your heart
knows I know the world is doomed because
because that's just reality but
nevertheless I have a responsibility to
my children. I have a responsibility to
my neighbors to the people I love to try
my best
regardless. And that's what faith in God
that's what faith in each other that's
what true love really is. Does that make
sense? Okay. All right. Great great
question though.
And I'll be honest with you, I'm
confused by this as well, okay? Because,
you know, I I'm I'm so western in my
thinking, but I think um again, it's
it's you've got you have to train
yourself not to be so logical at times,
right? Okay. Any more
questions? Does that make sense to you?
Okay.
Oh, great question. Why are the Russians
so pessimistic? Okay, first of all, it's
really cold in Russia. Okay, if you're
if it's cold, you're not you're not that
optimistic, right? Second of all,
Russian civilization is is built on
violence, right?
Um the Americans basically went over and
were able to steal the the continent
from the natives. and they just didn't
really put as put that much much of an
existence. But Russia was built on
tremendous violence. Not only did the
Russians have to um get rid of the
Mongols, they'd have to fight the
Swedes, the Germans, uh the uh French,
they fought everyone basically. It it
was like a never- ending process of war.
And then and then the their conflicts
within their people. Okay. So Russia is
a very violent society and so that leads
to a natural pessimism. Okay. So another
way of saying this is even though Russia
is huge, it's not that many resources
and people have to fight constantly
fight over these resources whereas
America it's huge, lots of resources and
people if you work hard you can obtain a
lot of resources. Okay? So that leads to
a optimistic attitude. So the question
really isn't why Russians are fatalistic
because most people are fatalistic. The
question really is why are Americans so
optimistic, right? Okay. Does that make
sense? Okay. Any more
questions? Was this clear to you
guys? Okay. I and I I I know it's hard.
Okay. But but I I will say like um
Russian civilization
um even though I personally would would
never want to live in Russia. Okay. U
because there's a lot of racism in in in
Russia. Um but it's it it is
a unique beautiful
civilization. Um and and I hope that in
the future you have a chance to read
Toys. Um because they are really the
best novelists ever. Okay. So um next
class we will start the uh Germans.
Okay, German civilization.